I brought some hand sanitizer did I pick
at all no what do you think Joe Jonas
authorization
he was offensively saying karate oh wow
oh good I think I said god I should have
said get up a proper Asian Parata I
don't know I don't know that's true so
this is my problem when i watch the
we're already getting into it watch the
news and we recording good we're live
don't tell me that when you hear someone
on go uh they're like a local la news
and they are doing a live report from
somewhere and then they're like well
this is Maria Gonzalez robbed my from
Pomona and then I go okay now I get it
and but then I go but what and then
people say well it's it's proper to do
it that way but then I go what region of
either of of Central America or Mexico
or war Spain Contino what where does
that mean that when someone says I would
like some chow mein that I have to say
jump me in as a white dude okay really
like so typical to ask that right you
are you are white obviously I mean I
just you have an exotic sort of your
hair tensed there's an up Rush going on
oh there's and your body looks your body
looks african-american oh wow a little
racist no just racist it's racist
Wednesday's Brian now hold on he looks
athletic and muscular here's the
interesting part - is American Samoa
again some honey his penis is diabetic
oh my god
yeah the lower part of his caucus
doesn't wanna touch tattoos right just
under the head just right up on the you
know the war tattoos on their ass oh my
god no no no good we worked it out this
is a very nice studio
yeah they serve mean it really shows
your success well we've done very well
relations congratulations to you well
thank you you said you said he an
athletic build B did you know you played
Division one football night I receive
you know that but I heard that a long
time ago I think you played tight end at
USC god damn it's all right Washington
man things a huggie only pac-12 school
that matters what right yeah I see
that's a fun intimidating thing to pull
out but then I look at you and your ears
and I go that's the most intimidating
thing on the plan yeah that's a
different night I Jews aren't in just
like it's just that just shows you yeah
you've done it yeah I guess I wish I
could just call a flower in my ears now
yeah you could just I could start but
then played a color with it you played a
Colorado why do you want all four years
did you play all four years no no I quit
after a year and a half I never played
is a red shirt red shirt walk on I was a
walk-on then four so then they saw how
bad I was and then then I got better and
then they redshirted me when I was a
sophomore right and then I my ADHD
kicked in and I left so you know how
retro and like walk on yeah so you're
like the runt so you're like you run the
scout team so let's say he was playing
SC he would have to be the scout team
guy infused I didn't he'd have to mimic
what that guy does exactly it's the
worst job in the world right you're not
what he you had a scholarship and were
there for a reason
hold on I was a walk-on for a year and a
half and then got a scholarship good for
you and he was also like a like a Ivy
League so you played lacrosse and you
got that you refresh yeah yeah I played
lacrosse at another show he's a really
Vassar right knows
he's very good athlete at Harvard yes
but he was funny he always says to me I
I don't know from this but I look at him
I go you're huge and he says not that
huge you see the guys I played football
with you see and then I'll see guys who
and I go oh Jesus Christ
yes sir that's what you're competing
with so you're a big guy and I look at
him and I go am I crazy
Joel's bigger than me I'm sorry Baba now
look at Joel is how do you draw a big
case for yeah I'm sorry kid but you
you're the other yeah but we your
different faces but you have the cool
you know watch a hipster named Jojo you
about to 22:15 I thank you for saying
that now I'm about to a seven to a 7
throw Sam down a bit now such a thing be
Joseph now he's dropped down to 190
about a year yeah how did you feel that
would be partially for me my stomach
muscles shred city did you know when you
got jacked is in that movie that the
horror movie tank before seeing it bring
it up the hope that little and I'm it's
one of my favorite hormones what is it
so goddamn go near you delivers deliver
us from evil yes thank you
no you were acting heavy and you could
have been acting heavy you know who took
your job you were you know God job who
in a quiet place John Krasinski oh no no
he never played ever had that job oh wow
yeah they're a temp yeah that's it's
that's uh oh there's me being
interviewed or with you detective on
there hunting this bad guy down already
Jack tonight he says he's thin and
that's I waiting for Wow
that's Eric Bana ya know it described in
the thing it said you have to be you
were much bigger than Eric Bana and he
Eric was is big yeah then I had I went
to the gym like well he was Hulk I'm a
fan of his he's such a I hate him I'm
going on the record here and say he's
Jesus joke ah he is way too so I meant
when my wife first met him she was like
yeah he's very attractive
yeah and I said you hit very as in you
don't put that word in front of me I he
was like he just like looks like a movie
star and I was like okay is he
Australian he is he leaves a sketch
had a sketch yeah you supposed to be a
you want to be coming yeah he had like
the number-one sketch show in Australia
oh well then he got this movie called
chopper which you guys would love so
I've ever seen it's alright based on a
true story
yes love's a real guy and Oh based on
that take a look at him you got yeah
[ __ ] oh yeah he wasn't joking
alright well he got yeah yeah and then
he and then he started getting cast
internationally in all these serious
roles oh well
and no one knew ISM knew him as a
comedian I mean that's that is a
oscar-winning performer one of my
favorite movies that and Bronson with
Tom Hardy those two movies you go oh and
there there's the real chopper yeah yeah
did you like Tom Hardy's a spider-man
venom
see I love venom everyone hates honey I
thought it was great uh were you
distracted by his accent no not really
look like Tom Hardy I get that a lot you
know I think it's a compliment you
couldn't be bigger
he's 140 naturally well we're not we're
not you know say you're the same size as
Dan Hardy
I don't know you're probably get all the
time you're probably Tom Hardy sighs who
would you say I'm a little bigger taller
I'm definitely stronger hold on you went
mmm don't you what no don't do that
go ahead no go hmm I say that cuz I did
a movie with him now with Tom what with
Tom Hardy but you did yeah with which
one Tom Hardy which movie a movie called
warrior low a hell of an actor though oh
yeah is that the high that's the fighter
one yes ladies the brothers yes yeah
thought of no desire so warrior you'd
live it I don't like fight move there's
nothing to with fighting you'd love it
oh it's a story brothers brothers have
to fight phenomenal movie yeah you were
great in that you played what is
accounting feel like you're being okay
so I'm gonna ask you I played you like
city yes he was
Jackson at Bryan Callen you played
basically the Joe Rogan okay the Joe
Rogan role but you did I did you beat
yeah
so that was he's a lot I get where I
keep doing it quietly and you're being
in like a Socratic thing you're you're
asking questions but I think you know
the answer so thank you for saying that
I was Socrates I didn't I didn't give
you a but I was a handsome son of a
[ __ ] take a look at me let's zoom in on
that picture I'm listen you need to fill
out the 401k no this is gonna be a lot
of money and you want to put it away
no and no that's not use it when you're
60 because it'll grow those weren't the
[ __ ] lines your suit was tailored on
well yes askew actually it's a tighter
suit demands that ankle right because
now are you it looks like you're you're
in a fight in that scene well my natural
I have a martial presence my natural
tilt my chin now so if you swing at me
you're gonna catch forehead Moe and joel
edgerton Zinn that too huh yeah I'm not
gonna catch forehead he's a monster and
a good writer and a director yeah
don't both guys are those are two minds
of acting yeah and and then you got you
in there and that's just great for you
trying to trick no I knew what you're
saying that I'm doing it I don't know
you do realize it don't I really now go
shoot just Hey Joe do you have anything
to do with talk soup coming back did
they call you like a is this cool to do
all the soup my friend the Scott's here
this was talk soup though and this is
the soup right well no mine was thus
okay because that doubled when that talk
soup was only about talk shows way back
when before you were born when you were
hitting out of graduate school I don't
like it okay well this is there oh hey
yeah that was me yeah all right
different there are a lot of different
hair yeah they're going on yeah they
know they I I have nothing to do with
the new one nothing I mean I was fired
four years ago or three years ago I
didn't know that I did yeah fine I
thought you're just like I'm [ __ ]
done with the know they are they it was
it wasn't they you know they were like
we're not doing the show anymore and
well it's I felt like it was a big hit
it did was it did very well but now this
is you can just cut this out cuz this is
boring as hell at that time you had
Chelsea and Joan Rivers and myself and
they we it was like comedy that they had
it's like two hours of comedy a day
basically and then the writers guild
came in and said hey you guys are have
written comedy and at that point and II
still to this day is one of those cable
networks that does has there's no unions
so there's no actual writers they're all
producers so that's why I would like the
Kardashians there's no writers right
even though everything's written and
that's why they can air the show
endlessly they can be here a show twenty
five times a week so they used to run
the soup like thirteen thirteen or
fourteen times so then they said you've
got you got to pay writers all we're
gonna protest and I was and the writers
like fantastic and I was like great
they'll get paid more but then then
chose Chelsea left Joan very sadly died
and then we were the last man on the
island and they and then II saw oh every
rerun costs this much money that does
not fit our model we this was very this
was very boring what I just said so they
were like it's interesting so they were
like goodbye and I were like okay and
then and then that I hope the new girl
does well do you know Baretto I just
shot her a few weeks ago at the laugh at
yes she's gonna work the the world
exploded and now you're here covet free
hopefully well my gonorrhea is pretty oh
no cages yeah well we're gonna take a
look at that you don't you want to don't
mess with this couch afterwards no no I
am so like a day and turn up the heat
okay we'll turn the heat up any of your
friends have it no no and I'm like oh
hell shade god
I know Jade Oh Jade I know every just
really should talk soon it's a big deal
for her that's [ __ ] awesome gonna be
nice I open it yeah I hope it does for
hope that you know fine I don't know
what does in this I've worked for you a
ton I don't know what does well on me
besides the Kardashians it has very much
tougher come the Kardashian Network but
they are some of the most recognizable
people ever well they're doing it for a
reason
I mean they've steered into it very
smartly
and I mean it still is a huge huge but I
don't know what I'm not sure what else
is on e these days it's not like I
you know I love botched alright that's
that does well think that does well yeah
I'd like to go in there what do you know
blah you know box one to fix my hair it
looks great
you know botch want to fix my ears no I
like yours yeah do they hurt ever know
isn't there a thing though that it can
they can become painful when it's
happening it's like awful hurts so bad
but then they just gets harder it
calcifies but that but can it can a
break alright well you can't like
there's been fighters where they gets
really hard and they do know like
scuffle and they like rip off some
that's not good
okay I knew that you so yours is from
wrestling my grappling right he was in
the UFC heavyweight for ten years ten
years
yeah right is that fair not ten years
six wasn't you CFE six but for bad eight
other that your faces did you don't
there no thanks man no a big scars we've
got his nose broke so what's happened
ace 42 you Brian what's your excuse for
you know I had my nose broken a couple
times like and yeah Frank that cuando
from with the cuando cuando cannot they
come foo I mean whatever it is my box
you box that boxes this morning oh who
did you fight okay so I just today was
hitting just mitts so again it omit nope
I said mitts see and now you're doing
that thing about him nice okay are you
alright see what I keep doing and I
apologize okay but hey I don't know why
I'm telling it what do you what do you
do for your work deaths I pretty much
just lift weights and then at your house
yeah and then I have an air dying bike
of course now to do it you know the
Aerodyne thing it's such a beast
when I played football they would get
say a sit on that thing for ten minutes
there's like no problem to go keep it
above sixty RBI or whatever and gonna
die the best athletes on the team would
fall oh you died but then you you have
like a strict diet you have to be doing
somebody just genetically thank you and
how catch he's Norwegian he's up
Scandinavians your descent I'm what
explains this now now listen I'm Irish
Italian oh yeah combination in American
it's a rare car
that's an Italian didn't get a lot of
the height you got some nice tits on you
there that's that I don't that's not a
good example well that's but
congratulation we go thank you
yeah there's a Jim rash yeah you know
some weird dieter what ah no I just
strategically so this morning I had two
cups of coffee and a graham cracker yeah
that's something I liked you did see
because I was like I'm never gonna not
eat pasta I'm just not gonna eat all of
it yeah that's right
portion control is and then I have you
know six bottles of wine at night yeah
and that is a yes surprise good I don't
do it that's what I do I drink I like to
drink obsessed with put Tiger King and
I'm almost done with it
no you're almost done you I can't
believe you I need to get I need to a
show and because your show it's seven
series some part series alright because
that new Call of Duty that warzone thing
just happened and I can't not play that
oh really are you are you a video game
guy I love video games really how much
how old are your kids
twelve and fourteen they're boys no yeah
they're so it's fun they're so good well
one of them is in the Madden like net he
I watch him kick people he's 12 and
online yeah and he kicks people's asses
all over the place and he was like he
will just Hugo watch this and he'll drop
back as the quarterback and just run all
the way backwards and I'm like I think
you're gonna probably get tackled here
and he just dazzles around them and I
was like man there's a ball I never
thought about that but they play a lot
of 4/9 you know what you know that weird
is when especially when we were kids
that try to be mean but when we were
kids like kids my dad say you know if
you can play an hour of you to give me
go you're outside for two hours every to
give them outside for two hours now I'd
like okay I make sense I'm gonna be a
loser but now kids are making millions
of dollars playing video game million
millions upon millions of dollars it's
like a legit career they play get on
Twitch make money
there's leagues there's teams oh you
know I like to watch other making stuff
you time out they sell out staples
people watch these kids I love these new
jobs that come along with technology
nobody thought it's just tough cuz
they're because now you used to be like
dude you're gonna be a loser fight you
just play video games kids might shut
your [ __ ] mouth this kid makes 12
a year of Yahoo the games I mean ninja
kind of broke they'll keep probably is
the most famous you know mad ninja ever
I think he's trying to deal with adidas
I don't or nice and then there's like
that new cell can you got your loser
fruit and you got your Lachlan it's
their hats they're huge and like 20 kids
will just play it watch other kids play
video games when I was a kid I [ __ ]
hated watching people play video games
yeah I was chomping at the bit to get
the fit yeah of course now these kids
are off to the sides watching these
watch right yeah what's wrong with you
I've been to the overwatch League Turner
I've gone to them Oh to watch them play
on a movie screen is it good they're all
people are screaming like they're a
Tasya and they're so good my son who is
eight watches on YouTube watches really
good for tonight players yes and the
other day me came running down and said
he was like mad because I suck at
fortnight up garbage and I go well
what's the problem
what's the issue let's isolate he goes I
keep getting guilty and I never kill
anybody so I emailed so there's no point
playing I got well so we want to get
more kills and get killed less yeah okay
that's a goal is there something we can
look up is there a tutorial we can go to
like I break it down next I know yeah
he's looking up to comes running down
good day yesterday he's like I got three
kills I got three kills like freaking
out it at eight I was like is this good
that was a really good parenting yes
because our dads are gonna like oh you
know winning your video game yeah when
you run outside dummy yeah Mike I don't
give a [ __ ] but also when I was a kid
the big thing was arcade games so I
Mortal Kombat was huge remember there's
always that one nerd who nude all the
fatalities yes weird if you get those I
don't know where the [ __ ] did that guy
learned those there's no internet
there's nothing that kid just watched
other kids and he put in the time and he
spent the money and now now doesn't end
well and I do it he's do but he's a
serial killer now yes because he's
obsessed with all these fatalities he's
the type of my time yeah well they're
violent as [ __ ] I had to stop myself
from playing some zombie game because
these died he's chopping zombies heads
off and everything else I'm like I don't
know about this now well I bought I find
myself looking at his mother going I
know what do I do
I don't know what you do I bought my son
than a Nintendo switch cuz he wanted to
play Mario yeah and then you can
download game
there I'm like lot I advertise I love
Mortal Kombat there's Mortal Kombat 11
and get the joke and yet spawn who I
love so I downloaded it didn't think you
would get to it I go I look over his
shoulder that he's for mind you I looked
over his shoulder he's [ __ ] rip and
do two heads up yeah yeah I'm like well
this is it yes you downloaded it though
I don't feel like so this is not good
this game how to switch to what do you
do about that like I'm not sure what to
do about the inevitable surge of
Technology the kid is the kid look at me
and good my son goes it there's zombies
they're not real relaxed you know two
different lacks a zombie it's sad
because there's mmm-hmm a huge number of
adults that power prepared for a zombie
apocalypse yes I went to I for real I
was an army surplus store and there was
like the zombie apocalypse preparation
center and I knew the guy's name is Jack
he owns the place I'm like ha ha ha ha
and he's like if you only knew there are
people who really think it's real well I
want to do that now I want to buy I want
to be ready for the next pandemic or
something I just that's a reasonable
yeah but you don't go I wonder if
mythical creatures like zombies oh no
works are going to it yeah your friend
if you're that no I don't do that you
wouldn't be here no I had a talk with my
buddy Andy Stumpf was the SEAL Team six
guy word so he likes to do these tasks
civilians about what they would do
tactically and he shows you like scenes
from movies where SEAL team guys come in
and do stuff and he goes now what was
wrong with that right
so I was like I don't know you're like
the uniforms they're all wrong they do
they do tell you like little things when
you're was a high level soldier
identical well they came in they used
the silencers they shot people so that
nobody could hear anything cuz silencers
I know so stylish he goes not silent
very loud in fact that's the sounds if
that's a suppressor and also and I said
yeah yeah well they got to make it
quieter and he goes well there's also
the fact that the bullet breaks the
sound barrier did you think about that
I'm like no I don't know about these
things
subsonic rounds those don't and now
you're now you're speaking my language
not a Navy SEAL dude no yeah no but it's
just funny how we we go through all
these things about how to you know what
how would you know anyhow so I said to
him I go that's why I would use
I'd have a crossbow division and we'd
all come in there with crossbows they're
[ __ ] very quiet and by the way right
through you and you write like this you
go you ain't as easy to reload yeah ok
ok there are probably contraptions where
you can reload them better than that
that little spinning thing you there's
the thing you can crank it so you have a
real odor you'd be you'd be my real odor
behind me what's wrong wait what's this
what is the situation we're in our
people in VR we breaking into a home or
we're breaking into a into a compound
with some bad guys ok guys now we're
gonna have to hoof it alright your big
kid you're gonna have to carry most of
the gear I have to carry you
ya know Master Blaster lifted right no
no okay no you have to carry the first
aid you have to carry the water you have
to carry the radio you marry the Anne
Frank thing and the crank
you gotta crank back you mean my loader
when we come in week week signal load oh
yeah right means load up to load up load
up uh-huh that looks like we're touching
dicks two centuries okay so when you see
a person in front of me
yeah that I can't see yeah how do you
signal to me like silently that there's
a person like this I stroke your head
uh-huh very good that's making noises
and you're saying hey you who think you
could just say there's a guy over there
if we you're too loud if you're allowed
to talk you're uh huh they smell good so
[ __ ] straight thank you what's going
on this is I'm gonna take them out I'm
gonna stack them I gotta wait till they
stock you know you stack girls I stack
those guys how do you stack a girl okay
will you put one on top of the other
okay you do yeah doggystyle I've just
seen an important house alone okay
yeah it's called roughhouse Sunday okay
so then is this all part of it you're
gonna wait till they're sitting on top
of each other or the stacked or like
ones behind the other okay then the
arrow goes straight through them yeah
now I'm gonna make I'm gonna sound I'm
gonna do it the sound of a night bat I
don't know if you know what a night pad
sounds like but I don't know a night bat
a pleasant it's like a 70s
easy-listening it is it's very hypnotic
and so that relaxes them and then suit
suit now watch how you die from
crossbell watch this
it's gonna go through my make the sound
of it go to the K it's that it's that
quick you don't think using your like
this no because I hit the heart Bubba
and Ric do you think maybe there'd be
the moment where'd they go
you hear phoom phoom and the guys like
and then it just bleeds and you didn't
even realize that it enter that's what I
think okay yeah I think that's all have
this your Navy SEAL friend recommended
this no I recommend to him this is the
apocalypse yeah that you're prepared
okay he didn't think it was a great idea
because he's wrong you're wearing a
winter cap you are wearing God you're on
it today man and you're an alcoholic
yeah and that's okay he drank this
entire Bob that's a thousand-dollar
bottle of whiskey is that really what is
it it's called 223 aged 23 years and you
say it one more time macoco yeah yeah
yeah that's him I could buy you a
whiskey drinker oh yeah I love whiskey
well at all we can we break open can we
have him try this
somebody ask them tug oh you're you're
oh this is like a high school party this
is very like pure pressure well go ahead
and Kennedy
that smooth that smooth whiskey it's
best whiskey ever have but I didn't have
some of that it's very nice isn't that
smooth finish it bed and finish that
it's tight now I'll sip it I like your
king piss god I love you I love that
he's drinking it that's great in that
nice huh yeah I drink I have a lot of
alcohol you do my home I can't I have a
storage unit full of it so you I love
that you died see I'm very impressed
with the guys guys he's a guy's guy Oh a
collection and an ass or collection
collection and a knife collection and
two jeeps this is I didn't know this is
my penis is it cannot be no no picked up
on any device not so small it's so small
but what what do you own Beast all's
visto las yeah I own one gun okay from
1805 oh really
no joke it's one of the it looks like I
could challenge someone to a duel so you
prefer to ward off joel mchale yeah this
isn't so yeah
do the one where I'm standing there in
the this one yeah watch this you prefer
to watch this yeah this will be I got a
small okay that's a bottle of shame and
leaping to do I hit a person with the
cork and then swipe over swipe over and
that is the court how that comes off Wow
look and I put meat in the shot too just
to you you had that's a scimitar and my
friend my writer friends sent that to me
and it they engraved on the blade it
said slide up the shaft until it
explodes and there is well you um
you have an easy bone structure you have
a Ben Affleck bone structure that's the
first thing I want to congratulate think
so oh but yeah you but like you but he's
thick yeah but you both can go up and
down I'm proud of you I stay more up
he's 270 just so I guys there's my place
yar it doesn't matter though yeah but I
don't 270 as a heavyweight is what you
want
yeah I'm retired I'd be staring at
comedy for last five years yeah alright
well here's my secret no
I get it how much were you when you play
when you five I was like 240 something
242 that's when I love for watching that
stuff because I'm not no never never
Brian when you broke 150 what did you
think you know all right I wasn't
blessed with let me see that I'm very
much and see the it really should looks
like I am some sort I have you know I'm
just just clinging to masculinity I love
him my goal is I like ideas to cook the
perfect steak at all I'd like that is
now I'm about to do that is similar
tonight can you give me your your
perfect steak recipe yes I mean what
kind of a steak is it it is a it is a
New York Strip all right and how thick
is it's about that thick
about everything yeah well it might be a
little thinner but no it's an inch it's
an inch is it from Whole Foods
no it's from butcher box okay so no meat
for now phenomenal mate
phenomenal meat is also the name of my
book and the journey of a porn star know
I hear okay so the key first the key is
take that thing out of the refrigerator
the two hours before you're gonna come
attend and definitely if it's yes don't
let it if it's there's other steaks on
it separate all that okay you do not
need to put salt on a steak beforehand
you don't know it is there's different
philosophies like oh it tastes like salt
when you get up you can add salt but a
lot of people would say that the
hydrates them yeah so then are you using
a BBQ using a pain I'm using a pan
unforced Lana that's fine that's fine
all right so I would recommend so you
pre-heat your oven to like a 325 okay
and you want to get that pan so if you
have like a geat you have the ghee
without the F key okay
ghee is butter without the fat clarified
butter because or you can do the brown
butter method which also is probably the
taste really good brown butter method
yeah where that just takes a little bit
more time so when you put you put the
butter in and then when it turns brown
you can see the little black but those
are the solids those are the fat coming
off than you well okay so I'll do the
first method all right so you get that
pan
smokin hot right and you don't use olive
oil use either ghee or use a canola oil
because they have higher smoke point yes
smoke points and then you want to do
one minute aside on that near one one
minute okay just now I get that hot
though that oh well you want it you want
that pan to be smoking before you use it
our point it you can I've done steaks at
30 seconds side oh you 30 seconds aside
and you stick it in that oven for about
six minutes why if it's one steak is it
more than one steak one steak then you
want to you we put more monster sorry
that's not doable for sale I see no then
you know and so then you want to do that
like five and a half minutes six minutes
in that oven because you want like a
medium-rare right yes you wanted then
whole pan yeah off the stove yeah no pic
put the whole pan in the up not cover it
do not cover it come on put it on the
lowest level of your oven okay and let
it let it do its 325 for six minutes
pull that steak out walk away from it
for ten minutes it's ready to eat but I
get off the grill yeah the butter is so
yeah and then and then do I put some
salt and pepper on there I wish we had
talked beforehand I would have brought
you some salts realize I have way too
many con you want to put there's so many
different then you can put anything you
want then you can salt and pepper you
can there's I put some chili flakes
sometimes you don't marinate your sorry
cup so I have done that yes definitely
so well the brown butter method I love
so if you tie like that with a bone-in
ribeye because it's a little bit of a
thicker bigger steak but you get a pan
you get you put your butter in it turns
brown you put that stake in there and
then you start putting that butter on
there and even though it's burned it is
burnt
absolutely burnt but that there's a
nutty flavor to burned butter yeah I
don't know I'm turning because you knew
the smoke point but uh that infuses into
the steak and it's wonders so I realize
the best cut yeah that's my favorite
bone in ribeye and when the bone is in
then it that lets a flavor out but New
York's are so good because the
kind of have the combination cuz a filet
mignon is no fat at all which he makes
it tasteless in a weird way to let's
taste but people also go oh it's the
gret but then you get some of those
dry-aged bone-in ribeye is like eating
I don't like dry aged you don't like
that I don't like try it it tastes funky
to me the meats on it that's its eyes
moist it's almost like you need to go to
a pl steakhouse my friend and have their
two places I've had the best steak Felix
Republic uh yeah dude scope scope us
t-bone ain't bad bro no okay sounds like
we need to do a little work yeah where
we around yeah cuz APL he dry-aged his
stuff for 400 days now doesn't have
skunk that you really see I don't like
the skunk this not mean it is rotting
meat technically you ever seen it before
they cut up all the fungus - its disgust
mean it's controlled brought by always
think about it what's yoga yeah that's
good that and that knife he makes the
knives which hiked it even where is this
where is this restaurant at the Taft
building at Hollywood and Vine don't
know anything about him what's it called
a pl steakhouse it's a new place it's
been there for about two years that's
folded metal he's making his own knives
he's folding the makeup and he had why
there are about a thousand dollars
apiece you can't buy them and then one
guy try to steal him and he got it back
wow there's Adam oh he's awesome I love
a lot of maniacs yes he's obsessed he
also trained in France he was trained in
France and then and then he worked for a
billionaire in Arizona who had a ranch
who never showed up to the ranch because
it was like a vacation and then he
grounds crew from Mexico taught him how
to barbecue let's go there tonight dude
well they look at their takeout menu
it's all they take out I mean be now
they have to yeah love to go every
restaurant did not know anything about
that
everything's been on Hollywood and you
live in Hollywood I live in Studio City
people yeah they do a matzo ball soup
huh they got yeah he's got a lot so it's
bar but république is also public is
yeah it's it's fantastic
is that your favorite restaurant where
do you guys live I like I have several
favorite restaurants but you know
as far as in Hollywood Republic to me is
the best food I've ever had
Wow it's some of the best food I've ever
had period oh hell have you not eaten
there it says that the bread and the
butter just just the Normandie daughter
they give you it's I mean Isis that with
the number of tables they have yeah
quality is a big room husband and wife
team husband from San Diego I had to
meet him cuz you know I just pay
attention in these things he's such a
[ __ ] artist and everything he does is
unique and different his wife was a
runner-up that for a James Beard Award
for her desserts her desserts are just
unbelievable and oh by the way it's in
Charlie Chaplin's old studio one yeah
what was the restaurant there before it
kept now what's that there was another
restaurant in that Felix Oh company lamp
and company yes Felix Felix is down on
Abbot Kinney
yes Felix's Oh have you so so Rogan is
obsessed now because I took him Felix
yeah and oh I played him in a movie he
played his accountant right joe-joe
again that's a question that I think you
know the answer to now I play Oh myself
talking about this yeah I played Bryan
Callen alright so yeah no you're not
though you see you're not I know I came
in here I've been there once maybe we're
a fabric and is it weird that where it's
where the old Joe used to be come on Bob
I can't believe you ever been there I'm
gonna take you you traveler buzzing oh
they're right no Travis is it well
drivers who got bought out so he doesn't
own Julia or just an oh wow
yeah the prawn does his part you guys
been to that nomad downtown no but heard
good things look up nomads and you will
see the most it's the most beautiful
setting for a restaurant but yeah it is
what's your total kana that's
outstanding
yeah that oh yes yes I mean look at the
bathroom I'm not kidding look it's that
type of nomad bathroom Los Angeles and
yeah pool table I've heard good things
about that place the bathroom god damn
it there's a bathroom look it's the safe
yeah oh wow come on that's fantastic
there was a time in America yeah there
was so much money and I like you know
yes build the most beautiful building
you've ever seen it will put your money
in it
yeah are you guys buying that Trump
saying because the economy would be back
by Easter I'd like to be back by East
well I'd like to be but yeah I think
that's realistic I don't think you can
make that prediction the governor right
now is like that ain't have them well
well how can you predict how the disease
is gonna spread cuz right now we're on
the trajectory it's like New York like
we are going up I feel two things are
gonna happen
one is that hopefully some of these
drugs will mitigate the severity of the
infection absolutely and then - I think
I'm gonna back this up in a second that
the mortality rate will not be what
people feared so when you do a mortality
rate and they say 1% then they say that
could be if a hundred million people get
it that's you know the problem with that
is that that's yours that's it you've
got it you've got to take the more
talented people in affected the people
infected you've got it it's a skew
statistic who is infected and of the
infected who actually have it how many
people actually die if you take the
diamond princess 700 people on board the
cruise ship yeah yeah I think they were
study kids yeah it is there was a 1%
more at 7 people died right uh there
were mostly yeah they were mostly very
old and many had pre-existing conditions
that would be in that case you know in a
very very tightly controlled petri dish
where nobody had everybody was so
exposed to each other that was a 1
percent mortality rate um so you're
saying because it's the you think that
the I don't know how your right is going
to average out at something very low and
which means according to to open up so
to epidemiologist out of Stanford wrote
a piece for The Wall Street know if I'm
Stanford better but no man Stanford
Stanford college universities that knew
yes that would be no that would be in
California and you know that now here's
the thing they they had a very
interesting breakdown of of how all of
these statistics were hearing of a four
percent and they are very unreliable and
and almost certainly false and they're
they're hardcore scientists who you know
I know I agree that it's hard to know
what to believe at this point
but we do have anything more that's what
is things are as we are gaining all this
knowledge but to say hey it's gonna open
up to say like I'm too reckless it just
seems like it you can't really plan but
I think what like a friend if you were
to start working out for the first time
in your life and to eat up can't say I'm
gonna be on the olympic IFBB think Joel
know you've done that again now Ida
train I train you haven't seen my shirt
off
yeah and and and so be careful because
I'll show you maybe but don't Trump
Trump is saying you're a few shirts yes
three you know chilly I keep my mid body
warm he still wears a wife beater like
he's 1907 it makes me feel a little more
muscular I get that yeah that makes a
lot of sense I lights my shoulder hey B
but I think I think what Trump is saying
is yeah Corona is bad but when you look
at the statistics it's pretty low but
the economy going to [ __ ] is what we
can't have so anybody under 50 that
doesn't have outlined conditions get
your ass back to work great and the old
people cuz the Boomer remove a virus the
old people if you around them stay awake
I think that's reasonable and the
question that that has to be asked is to
what like to mitigate how many people
always sacrifice so we can but where
where do we mitigate infection there you
have to take certain measures where does
that end and we are does anybody know
what 35% 40% unemployment looks like
that's not a pretty sight my fit my
thing is is China it started there right
13 bad soups started there and there's
how many billions of people in China and
they've had it the worst and they're out
of it now they're booming now in 60 days
to get two months but they know Yuri
this is I can't get a cup and I'm
looking for yeah pour him some of that
where's your cup oh wait oh man genius
no I just I go I here we all the plan
you just can't plant if you look at what
China did when that the way they
lockdown was way more severe than we're
locked down and but if you look what
they did also in South Korea as soon as
those as soon as they started easing it
the infection weight rate went right
back up yeah so I I just I couldn't
people go like by this date it's gonna
be blank I'm like mmm when you make that
plan that's gonna the California
governor says 8 to 12 weeks I don't know
before people know what Gavin Newsom is
[ __ ] talking about because Gavin
Newsom would have to explain to me how
he's gonna keep the economy from
literally freshen because he's a [ __ ]
dummy like I I this is the kind of stuff
that drives me crazy as your van he's a
good-looking dude Beeks good spin I've
had plumb jack he makes that one he does
he's part of that that makes me angry
it's great one it's great that makes me
very angry I'm a white guy got Tyumen
gavin newsom plum jack
[ __ ] that can you see the best-looking
governor probably yeah yeah he's a
ladies man
bilingual yeah I got a problem with him
yeah he's sitting there they're killing
it yeah mine yeah career politician yeah
he does look like those like Amanda he
looks like them yeah he looks yeah he's
he's the movie version he's involved
plum jack winery yeah
goddamn it and you enjoy that wine it's
a very good wine you're welcome
it's a very good but I think I do think
you need to plant that whole thing like
every epidemiologist says when you talk
to them to like plan for the worst and
hope for the best better like a it's
gonna be fine yeah yeah I think you have
to that's true so so 8 to 12 weeks that
sounds like an eternity it does but I
think 12 weeks is unrealistic it also I
think it's unrealistic as well but we're
all kind of guessing here but the the
fact that we can spare a trillion
dollars or whatever it is I was like oh
you did that who truly I was also we're
doing great right that's a thousand
billion that's a thousand billion that's
two thousand billion dollars but how I
don't think any of us were questioning
how many million is a lot of no no that
that's two thousand billion dollars how
many millions is a billion how many
millions a thousand million
so there you go how many ten thousands
all right all right man I don't know man
this is getting a little crazy now I'm
just I'm done reducing the number anyway
so in conclusion we figured it out wait
I just I
the country is obviously dealt with when
I hear people like it's scary we're all
hunkered down we're not touching each
other that much and but you
great-grandparents there was two world
wars yes and a huge depression yes
how about h1 came out with that what
yeah what or SARS yeah do you remember
in lockdown for h1n1 or SARS h1n1 killed
this is strangely unprecedented but this
is truly novel because they he ever seen
in it might have been engineered there
is evidence that they see the clouds for
the rain in the last two weeks you just
spit out damn a choice Joe you're trying
to alpha me right size 13 all right [ __ ]
man he's run big Duffy yeah you can't do
that with your feet cuz you're clearly
trying to one-up me like that one right
here I want to hear are the how it was
all planned well he knows evidence I
didn't say that I'm just saying people
DNA I may know some people all right
scientists who are noticing that it does
look different can you give us the name
of that scientist could have escaped
from the Wuhan it could have escaped
from a bomb
lab why did you back up Wuhan twice to
say it even as if you knew how it's
pronounced because I speak different
languages like like the ones that
depending on where I've been I am pretty
prefer language do they speak and move
on they speak what do they speak yeah
Chinese what can I say why you say it so
quietly because you're saying it a
slightly different way it seems like to
hide the way you're changing hey Jimmy a
cat is it racist to call because I call
it Mandarin from my dad he's like that
no Mandarin is a language Mandarin is
the main length
Mandarin is the main form of Chinese
spoken in the main
now why don't you visit my Mandarin in a
certain way that you've been saying the
other thing Mary I'm marrying him I see
but you know how would you say these is
spoken in Hong Kong so they're different
a lot of different dialects yeah but
Mandarin for the most part cuz the
Yangtze and the Yellow River and kept
people speaking the say Yangtze and the
Yellow River yes it's not the same river
there's two rivers the month is called
Jack's yellow in Chinese and the other
one is called yellow yeah because it
depends on the s you are here talking so
the Yellow River hang it up in China Qin
bring us it up ramp the [ __ ] yeah
bring up the racist
River believe hey sister hey don't you
think Trump's can get reelected if he
pulls pulls us out I think it's a very
interesting time and I think yes uh-huh
right okay yes women that's the
principle river and then the basin and
the Yangtze River oh you have are they
different rivers run okay I apologize I
was right and I knew I was you you're so
small on these chairs it sounds like I
sometimes go okay you can't know this
thing that small he's a young person
okay and but then you're older and no
see and so I'm really sorry you've been
you gave me a credit you apologize but
then you insulted me twice so win Oh
just raise yeah just you so the Yangtze
and the yellow yes so Mandarin is the
main language spoken mmm yeah okay so
it's not racist safe Mandarin no
Mandarin is Alea why would your dad say
that when you study Chinese you study
Mandarin Chinese audience they judge you
if you study Chinese did you study an
answer in front but um oh yeah yeah what
and elta what does that mean huh I just
said thank you and no my job that's a
Chinese word whoa what causa
oh [ __ ] let's have that's slang for
dog the type of food you can get it
almost any okay what do they speak in
such one
such one easy catch one easy right who
said that recently I love when certain
people like like what the [ __ ] did Trump
say he's not articulate he said it's
less bad though it's much less bad now
it's very very bad but it's much less
less bad and I hope the Chinese virus
yeah that was hilarious
yeah he got a lot of [ __ ] for that it's
interesting thing to talk about it did
it did start in China well where was it
where was an engineer maybe in the
laboratory at the laboratory the Wuhan
labret well there is there is a bio lab
there by a war lab there so they do make
an engineer viruses just you know that
that's true yes yep so which means that
must have there's a theory among
scientists that actually is considering
a da da so it looks different what
scientists the one any of any scientist
okay well I'm not gonna go through their
name any names glasses how about just
one it's classified it's a good fine you
all want John stevens-johnson why not is
he because it's it's it's an alias yeah
it's probably probably yeah there did he
come up with us I'm sort of a lik sir
that it was his work though you say
abuse his work is what I'm saying
a lot of John Stevenson's in China in
1848 Steve is if I rollicking click
it'll light ornate okay so I would say
great guess yeah thank and so okay so
then you that you're saying from this
lab yeah that you're saying it's a
thirty that where they created this
right a pin out so I actually
well so so miles is a weird thing to say
because my parents live in Park City
Utah and they're actually friends with
scientists who are not only working on
this who are viral viral is just you
know they're just as insane no not just
submission but but but they are actually
staying at the house they were at there
some scientists at the house yes I have
to stand your dad's house um it's like a
hospital
it's a hostel for scientists and the
Airbnb for snipers Oh me call my dad and
ask him on it yeah yeah cause this don't
see B's this [ __ ] you oughta see
this let's see this watch my dad when it
comes to wireless your buds
you got that boomer when it's this man
we're wireless earbuds there's nothing
like it
if you want to zone out the world man
it's almost Corona you want to zone it
out yeah you need get you some Raycom Oh
ray cons are half the price of any other
premium wireless here but they're
actually what I use instead of my other
earbuds oh no you didn't Boyd there's
model that every day e 25 earbuds are
the best ones yet six hours of playtime
seamless bluetooth pairing more bass
more compact design that gives you a
nice noise isolating fit right they're
so comfortable they're perfect on the go
with your running with your in the waves
you can do everything you can run Joe
exotic wave some Tigers Oh does he
I usually when I do my martial arts I
swim with him when I'm with sharks
listen man yeah you've heard me talk
about before
how about Ray J snoop dogg cardi beat
they're all about it man now's the time
to get the latest and greatest from
recon get 15% off your order at buy rake
on comp /t f AP k that's by Ray conduct
on /t fat K for 50% off rake on wireless
earbuds
buy rake on comm /tf 80k no wires no
stems
he lives in Park City Utah and
scientists stay at this Airbnb of your
parents yeah I'm not in their house yeah
I know what's your dad's name Mike how
tall is he
six Bulls huge six four three hundred
pounds by 250 full hey Mike how do
pretty well I'm sitting here in the car
with your mother same one
our mother always I see how is that how
is your stock portfolio looking well
complain it was up a quarter million
dollars each day today the market came
off somewhat from its level because
Pelosi and Bernie Sanders got into the
act on this bill again I mean at least I
understand from from a text I received
III don't believe what I read because it
said it said that Bernie put a hold
pearly is one senator and doesn't have
the authority or power to put a whole
lot anything what is what is joel mchale
is probably and ask you some questions
he's a friend of mine a comic now let me
ask you this well is there any evidence
that that the kovat 19 i know you have
some signs of staying with you guys at
the house is that you true or false
one scientist one side what and that's
kind of sign that's what kind of seat
dietician so it is so did they mention
or is there been a talk about the virus
maybe having been engineered in a lab
and not being it may be more man-made
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
this is coming from a man who doesn't
offend Trump's and everybody has to
write their headline or write their
story they all have to have something to
fill the 24/7 news cycle so I feel sorry
for you got a discount so much of what
you're hearing one thing I heard would
be very very good to do is Andrew Cuomo
had a press conference and I've never
been a fan of his either but he had a
presence this morning and I listened to
the whole our New York's cases what
they're doing how they're dealing with
the lack of ventilators how they're
dealing with a lack of hospital beds and
their a rate of infection is coming down
over the last three their
all bad news New York is 15 times worse
than the next state closest to it which
is really kind of interesting yeah no
that makes sense I'm gonna have to get
back to the podcast but I appreciate I
appreciate the insight no how can we fix
the economy go you guys I'll call you
guys later and and over/under do you
think we open back up in two weeks or
not no all right
all right pal see you later talk to you
later I love you dad what is that well
there it is nice Mahmoud longevity a
hand and body cream yeah [ __ ] who's
doing this so obviously it hasn't been
engineered I thought maybe there was
some talk about that oh no they're
Zionists yeah there's all sorts of em
yeah well how about that then you
believe in conspiracies I don't thank
you
do you read the book you'll believe in
any like JFK you know that I'm right
with you the moon know that no Joel
nothing no it's September 11th no here's
why no none of that do you need any time
that thought enters your brain you need
to call a flower that thought you need
to scrunch it up and beat it up beat the
[ __ ] out of it because why your that
whenever I hear like there's a then one
of them is the the Rothschild family
controls all the governments yeah I was
like oh yeah it's Nancy
well sematic when I go to the yet
totally on taste of my nose like when I
go to the DMV it sucks and what can they
can apparently they're doing a terrible
job
yeah and conspiracies are hard enough to
keep a secret between two people exactly
and they're hard enough to get between a
thousand the CIA think about
they I mean loose lips sink ships was
all through yeah was like you do not
tell anybody where we're going don't go
to a bar like that it's so hard to keep
a secret about anything so the [ __ ]
staged moon landing I mean are you
that's what I got that's the man who's
living a lie right Clinton said if you
were able to get a thousand people to
keep their mouths shut and stand still
yes III mean that would be the greatest
feat any human the government and people
don't behave that way and and I'll tell
you something about the federal
government they all have their agendas
and everybody's backstabbing each other
thank God for you yeah but what about
aliens go III don't I haven't seen any
proof of them yeah believe in them well
I well I don't I believe absolutely
there are other living things around our
universe way too vast vast for that not
to be happening that the the coincidence
and of other planets being able to
sustain life is absolutely the
percentages are very good for that no
have you seen like some of the tape like
some of the pilots like in the Air Force
were the record this no I when I see
stuff like that I'm like well that's a
real thing and that makes me go okay
that's an actual there are things you
can't explain but it doesn't mean yeah
but when I say like that it's the same
thing when people like there see there's
chemtrails and I was like what chemicals
what why would they do this my favorite
boxes that come out of your body well
well you got to sweat the toxins out and
they asked all these like people who run
these detox writers and they were like
and it's true that a doctor you can
detox for your liver and so when you
you've been an alcoholic there's ways to
detox there's ways to get heavy metal
out of your body but but for the most
part when they talk about detox and when
you talk about being neat and they'll
ask they asked all these I kind of like
healers and these people who rim what
are the toxin named them if you could
name the talk oh right but that don't
and they God that's not a conspiracy
theory it's more of its Johnny it's just
you stupid it's way to go like this on a
percent natural yeah well everything is
that's exactly true toxin would be toxic
to your body if you ingested diesel fuel
yeah you would truly have a touch so
that said so when I hear people go the
earth is flat which is a whole thing
and then when I hear people say like
well I'll bet they'll say stuff like and
I'll be like well how do you explain
that was like well I haven't seen that
and I go like have you been to Tokyo how
do you know it exists how do you know
what charm exists
how do you know Murr saying so I see it
it's just so it's on your skin and
eating a hole in your [ __ ] place it's
more people want they're missing
something from their lives and they want
to have on knowledge or they also want
to be part of a community yes yeah
behind them it's like hate trolls on the
internet but it's also like well you
only knew you're the conspiracy that the
government's against them right it's
just you're the government is a huge
messy place every government is it's
always a mess and the simplest
explanation is usually the right one
yeah which is everyone's backstabbing
and doing well some of it shake someone
like my JFK assassination now say here
we go
right you're not again just watch the
first 10 minutes of Full Metal Jacket
yeah and they'll be like I was a Marine
who it was a darn good shot and and why
you didn't have a good shot though all
right so everything that I've been that
window I've been it doesn't look like a
hard shot to me I haven't shot deer
personally i neuter and I all civilian
shotgun there's I mean that's why the
onion was so funny when in our dumb
century when it was like Kennedy
assassinated from 25 different angles
and then it just listed everybody who
was like Teamsters have you looked into
it though it's it's interesting where
you can see how if you are a person who
believes in conspiracies how it's super
easy to come to a few conclusions I it's
the same no no nothing no I got cuz I'm
FK suspect and these things come out
eventually I mean eventually even with
you but even with Trump because we have
all these files on JFK goes there's a
portion I can't release because it
creates some sort of pandemic come on
there's an interesting thing I will say
no the one site not pandemic but the one
thing I think is suspect the one thing
that does raise my prick Meyers a little
bit is that when Jack Ruby shot Lee
Harvey Oswald and he was a mob guy and
they loved him any they love
to the police yeah he shot him and we
don't know why and then he died of
cancer in jail so that there was
something going on but I don't doubt I
wouldn't try to kill Lee Harvey Oswald
unless there was a reason but well then
what about that what about this Joel
what about this you show you the car you
ready
you really hammered my name at the end
of that I'm just trying to really in
about Joel Joel well but how about the
car usually if there's a murder they
take it in for forensic and stuff like
that you know they cleaned it out and
then returned it okay maybe it's just
that you're not giving enough credit to
either human stupidity that's nice and
you might be right so my buddy right you
saying there's a lot of mishaps are you
if you try finding any case criminal
case where they didn't screw up
something on both sides yeah and it's
also people want to believe a certain
thing correct so they go for that so
find it dude you'll find if you're
looking for that sort of exact what
about epsteen epsteen oh that I do not
doubt that those cops were in the jail I
don't think he was killed I think he
absolutely were already Wow I believe he
was absolutely ready to hang himself I
don't know why why would you in your in
his position and hearing stories about
negligence in that time yeah I mean we
just watch lockup well it's not just
that like one of these my father who's
eight days it's almost eight he said it
was worth government and government had
a lot of friends and government forces
yeah yeah and one of the things you
always say is this he'll go and anybody
who I know who works in government
they're way more lap to say well there's
a huge incompetence in the government
yes it's not there is not a well-run
place there are there are major mishaps
major flubs there's all kinds of
backstabbing that's what's actually
going on for the most part so the idea
that there's a cabal of men who are
organized enough to set things in motion
and everything goes according to plan is
Hollywood [ __ ] it's really hard to do
it's just people
cooperate things go wrong right it's
just so I for me it's not that I don't
think that people would want would be
conspiratorial minded if they could but
for me I I think it's just too hard to
pull off I don't think those things are
eat as easy to pull off as people
there's a very good book called
conspiracy conspiracy B it's yes called
conspiracy B Wow conspiracy it's about
the takedown of Gawker the website yeah
it's one of the whole Cogan's cartoon
yes c22 and it's a great book and when
you they go over
it's so great because almost half the
book is like here's how I can real
conspiracy goes down and they talk about
when Peter teal expanded it to two
people and then to three people all of a
sudden things are getting really it can
all it it's getting very tense on
whether this secret of what they're
doing gets out but that's a true
conspiracy because because Peter Thiel
wanted to essentially sue them until
they out of existence so that guy had
this and a Gawker had had out at PSA
they added him as a game that he's a
billionaire and he went I don't care
what it takes I'm gonna take him down
and I'm gonna find a way to do it
without anybody knowing what's the book
of conspirators who he used how comes
just all conspiracies the back pockets
just called conspiracy but I don't want
to ma'am I'm letting up but it was very
convenient that the Hulk Hogan thing
went down that started happening like he
took that it wasn't a man with it he
would like oh that's an opportunity to
exploit to write to take them down again
it's great it's a great book and it's
called give and take now I'm considering
recommending books it was Apple Book of
the Year in 2017 I think by Adam grant
really good book do you write you a
reader I am wildly dyslexic so I reading
but I listened to everything I listen to
books on tape yes and right now I feel
like when I listen to books on tape I
don't get as much knowledge as if I were
to action I think it's in practice I
used to be the same way and I practice
now I can practice what listening yeah
because what happens is your mind
wanders as you're driving and stuff so I
send a podcast
oh I gleaned so much more from listening
reading integer now I do I'm just
reading all the Jack Reacher books now
so cool which are great
yeah but conspiracy is definitely I
would I would recommend it and the
battle the beautiful poetry have done
all that's fine 311 give and take is a
really [ __ ] good book about he kind
of like talks about how there are three
people in the world they're takers
they're givers and then there are
matters so I'll give you as long as you
give me that kind of stuff and he makes
a very very compelling case for in
politics Hollywood everywhere including
business people that give but give
strategically people are who are worth
it not just giving it to idiots but and
people who are just generous over the
long period over the long haul always
come out on top it's a really really
powerful book in that sense he does a
really good job I and people who take
takers scumbags whoever they might be
touches up with them it catches up with
them because and and what happens is
when you're a giver there's there's a
you could make the argument that people
start to really like you and they
conspire to help you and when you take
what happens is people go oh we [ __ ]
you over too and and there becomes this
naturally a net of neural sort of a web
of people who go the guy's a dick
nothing is just nap yeah and you lose
those comics though yeah yeah yeah right
I would also say when like the me to
thing came up and the people who knew
that people were dicks
they could not be happier to go oh yeah
that guy oh yeah just finally they can
do that guy's a piece of [ __ ] in that
and yes and it happens all the time with
movie stars who get out of control and
then they find one bad one flop and
they're like you're out that's it yes is
they word it right to get it out try
just trying to come for a reason right
and did you this isn't a conspiracy or a
me-too thing but maybe a little bit but
there's that comp I forget his name
Derek post and was really close with him
but he was a he was a Christian comic
really really clean but I mean sold
selling out theater huge theater
successful successful comic he's got
caught with a side piece was Mary got
caught with a side piece so the you know
the Christian community is like oh hell
no his entire tour for two hun 20 I mean
granted we didn't know Crohn's go but it
all states got pulled
that's him poor guy Russell sin so his
entire tour everything he can't do it
now uh lovin if [ __ ] forgive man well
yes it's a really good one oh so you
what you do know what is you have been
happening if y'all pent he will do the
classic I'm gonna go to rehab y'all go
to rehab for some reason and he'll he
will be super sorry for a year so here's
what he did girls would ask for tickets
and like getting it you know hot girl
ask for tickets like Kelly I gave you
tickets but let's hang out afterwards
you know
yeah I'm it sounds like he's got
something he's a normal dude there it is
sexual sin and addiction struggles and
so he's gonna go into rehab which is the
classic move and for about four weeks
you get out repent get back on tour dude
yeah I mean he um
he'll have to repent and then he'll go
back to doing things for or maybe just
or maybe just go hey Christian community
I'm going out on my own I'm gonna start
farming just for sinners that's what I
would do well and people gravitate
towards it yeah and I mean they got them
look at who Jesus hung out with he hung
out with that with the prostitute he
hung out with all the sinners so they
don't see you know the Christian
American thing where they've been they
it's a very strange thing just actually
about sex it's a puritanical show but
it's also like you must be perfect which
is ironic since the Christ was like oh
no no no everyone's [ __ ] up here and
that's that's how it is yes such a
bummer I feel for like that mm-hmm
yeah I know it's it's well he all but he
created he is whatever he created the
also helped stoke the image probably oh
yeah yes guys I go to church I have to
tell you do you I believe in that stuff
really that's but dude would you you
would say Mike you would say my act is
definitely not yeah you got your your
Christian or what are you oh yeah yeah
so you believe in that but not
conspiracies what I think yeah
yes but I don't believe Christian as a
conspiracy or Islam or these are sort of
wisdom that you can decide like what
would be the metaphor you can use that
Jesus was you know died and came back
right but that is
conceive yura see or is that just a
faith III which he said drinking I don't
think it's a little bit ridiculous to
believe that and not believe in some of
the sudden all I think cause if you
believe that how's that any different
than believing in zombies
well because zombies don't know what you
what you said me my belief in terms of
like there's faith what you're saying
yes yes I think the value of having a
perfect man Christ right would be that
if you can see what the exact perfect
example is and you as a human being
knowing that you're flawed can reach for
it and try to emulate it as best you can
that not to me is what the symbol of
Christ that one another was as you it's
like the thing of your enemy radical the
giver thing would be like the more you
give the more you're also loving turn
the other cheek and love your enemy is
of radical concept that you've never
been really I think there's some great
lessons you can learn from the Bible but
I think people that believe it you know
well each my page I would be a
fundamentalist no and I don't mean I do
of course I mean when people took it as
a science book it's not yeah yeah but
you could in theory say those first like
first there was nothing and then there
was light you could be like yeah that
was the Big Bang a metaphor you can use
it yeah you can use that as a great
metaphor people have people have found
the Christian Bible the Jewish Bible the
the the Islamic part of the Quran they
found great value in them when they
treat them 100%
you know when they treat them as
metaphor for how to live your life there
there are a lot of great lessons it
seems just the idea of restriction of
self restriction you know kind of like
having command over your appetites I'll
sort of have a bloop that's a how to
live your life like you mammals like
don't kill people don't walk across the
street and bang your neighbor's wife
yeah don't you like say some trouble you
could create a society based on those
things it saves it be rip morning you
know anyway Annie that said yeah I think
a lot of people would say that people
having faith sounds crazy and all that
and I was like yeah sounds pretty crazy
yeah I take there's crazy and I'm not
judging you I've says no Charlie man
that is as crazy as bleeding conspiracy
theories though I disagree with that
interesting because I think there's very
good evidence that we landed on the moon
yeah I think that's not staged I agree
and what I'm saying is there's no
evidence that Jesus came back from the
dead there is no evidence you're right
there's zero but there's very good
evidence we walked on the moon so but
that's one conspiracy too well I think
there's very good evidence and the earth
isn't flat yeah I think there's very
good evidence there's no sasquatches
very good evidence that that's not a
chem trail that's just a concept that's
made from yeah jet going to the
atmosphere no I think I think what
Brendon sings yeah I think I know if
there's inconsistency when the the
fundamental tenets of being a Christian
is the idea that you accept the fact
that Christ was man and there was a
person but he was father and son and he
raised that 3 days later his body was
seen by Mary and her friends or whoever
and some other people and came out of my
rib well that's how that's that's that's
Adam and Eve mmm
right that's in the Bible that's yeah
it's in there all right
yeah there would be Genesis yeah but
that's in the Bible yeah those before
yeah you came from my rib right correct
right and then I [ __ ] so what we've
you're well learned is that that guy
Crist who I'm Chris Ida to stay and I
just thought that was crazy when I
wouldn't York was telling about like
what the [ __ ] he lost all his bases his
entire family look at a lot of the
traditional especially fundamentalist
Christians if if like a mega preacher
comes out and says I think it's great
fine for gay people to be married and
it's good they'll lose their entire how
ridiculous is that that's ridiculous
it's so ridiculous it's what Kanye West
do replaces John Christ with who Chris
well he's been doing his Sunday service
thing you know and I that's where I hike
and they're so loud it's so loud yeah oh
wow Kanye West replaced them no [ __ ]
me dude wasn't a 19 December well it's
also ironic because I mean you look at
someone like Kanye who's who's had a
sinner oh but then once you once
you come commit in that in that in that
world that culture then I'm like oh
everything's fine
but he'll Chris will come back after
he's made his big huge pie he's made it
probably a thousand apologies now but
after his rehab I'm holding a bottle of
booze but but but he'll be but I
guarantee in a year he'll be back and -
because if he had said if he went with
that woman and left his wife that would
probably thanks Rob but he's he he no he
I was lost now I'm found
that's what'll happen he's got to be
which is yeah yeah it's a weird it's a
dude I've yeah I didn't mean to question
your faith drill I'm just saying at no
point do I feel that no no but I see
what yeah absolutely see your point yeah
but well he's going to hell so we know
that he is not going to heaven of the
Bible there's a height restriction you
know where if you're taller than a
certain thing you're fine I didn't know
that that's it when I first came to LA I
was going those Bible studies they tell
us it was my buddy whose balls deep in
the Bible and Jesus Christ and I got
remember that balls deep in Jesus's back
to you
so uh I go so what happens if you don't
like give yourself to Jesus
well corner you're going to hell I know
but my dad and my brother - the nicest
like most eleven people I know and my
mom and they don't believe in Jesus
Christ yes that sucks dude they're going
to hell like oh I'm not doing this
anymore
yeah oh I'm out dude no I guess they're
[ __ ] crazy that's crazy crazy that's
crazy
his died when I hear stuff like that I'm
like you gotta be kidding me it's nuts
that's I stopped going yep are you still
friends with that guy yeah we're cool
even though he thinks you're going to
hell yeah yeah no it does that do that's
what he was raised on that's his beliefs
are like I get it dude yeah I was rough
but I you know we were all raised I was
raised Roman Catholic but I don't
believe in the Pope so I'm you can make
those decisions but God I was raised
with no religion even though I'm
Catholic Roman Catholic
no I was an altar boy you know you know
you're you're in it but I wasn't in any
of it I thought it was all I didn't like
any of that stuff growing
yeah my dad went to the seminary now he
couldn't be more of an atheist I go what
happens when you die he goes extinction
yeah you go to church with my I bet if I
didn't yeah if I didn't believe like I
wasn't like a Christian I would
definitely be an atheist yeah absolutely
was it the agnostic what's the idea test
that's where you believe that in a
higher being but you don't believe like
I believe I believe no that's where you
just like I don't want to think about it
that's what I'm going on I was going on
I'll figure it out I believe this person
I think there's definitely a higher
intelligence a higher good a definition
for me you just did you did which is a
deist a deist would be a deity as a god
but a deist would be somebody who
believes that God made the world and
just let it go and is just it a Supreme
Being it goes to to its specific creator
who does not intervene in the universe
yep term is used chiefly he let it go he
just let it go you know you think do you
think man I made this the fuser and
agnosticism if so an agnostic is someone
who doesn't who do do says I don't know
essentially somebody who's like I'm not
gonna say yes I'm not gonna say no I
prefer to be sort of hundreds thereof
I'm an agnostic yeah but but a deist is
someone who believes in God and that God
created the world but does not interfere
in daily life so lets it kind of there
are laws to the universe he set those
laws in place and go and so the earth
continued just been according to its own
laws so there I am so there are laws of
nature there are laws of you know you
know a lot for someone like yourself
yeah he's been around a while dude I've
been around I love it a lot of both of
you me yeah forty-eight oh wow you look
good the youngest in the room I'm the
youngest in the room oh no cats the
youngest clearly she's black three I am
you're 53 53
37 42 2043 I would I'm not being shitty
chin I'd say he looked young I would say
so too I don't I thought you were like
well I thought you and I were similar
age yeah he's got tight skin but I'll
tell you something but wine really
breaks that down and now with that after
you hit about 50 51 you just start to
age quicker I swear to God
the difference between 50 and like 53
where like this trainer who's been
around forever and I said my he goes
don't be sprinting and stuff your
tendons are you know you're 50 I was
like I noticed that I noticed that my
[ __ ] calves of my tendons hurt more
than 50 or dollars to be sprinting right
Zoe told you yeah why would you spring
it I don't know who told you not to
sprint I'm tone oh no you should sprint
g3 cuz like I sewed like DJ's awesome I
hated squatting right yeah and I was
like I hate squats and then I'm like I'm
not good at them but you didn't call
getting old I did a lot of squatting and
you did the same thing and then I was
like you know what I'm just gonna squat
every day and I'm and then I'm gonna
deadlift every other day yeah I'm just
gonna start and because I couldn't do my
back was bad and I couldn't deadlift 45
pounds and I couldn't deadlift the bar
and I was like screw it I'm doing it
every day until I don't even think about
it
and I stopped running as well it was
like it's hard on your body and then I
was like no I'm just gonna do it and and
everybody gets strong when you do that
so now I can deadlift more than I did in
college practically what you didn't I
well thank you for asking
I've wrapped with like 315 and then I
can go up to I can get up to like four
but I don't do that a lot of way ever
I don't we sure you were do with the
trap are you doing the straight bar
straight bar no game you'll do 400 right
now four reps and that's his warm-up for
I'm not joking for deadlifting oh that's
that's a lot he laughs at that I don't
laugh I watched him do just let it warm
up with 400 grand I'm ready for this I
saw this with my own eyes ready for this
yeah 550 550 550 out 500 550 ready yeah
he did tense 10 reps hold on he did 10
reps 550 now ready he did instead 10
sets he did a hundred reps with 550
pounds
Joel deadlift and he did lifting objects
now it doesn't help
oh my god I mean his brother told me
that when Brennan was really dead
lifting when he was like dead lifting
over 700 pounds the bar would Bend he
was bending the bars zero and they were
mad at Brennan because he was bending
the bars he's theirs as your own Anson
ruining bars Lauren land that said
there's strong and then there's Brennen
shop yeah that's that's that's a
god-given it's a weird that's what you
should believe in God it's a weird cuz
he's a piece of [ __ ] and he just thinks
that that wasn't god-given it's been
working up how many of your how many of
your MMA friends like that big the great
athletes yeah how many could do that I
don't know let's go with zero let's go
with zero
Turkish get up with the full barbell 155
pounds Turkish getup just got up just
stood up whether or not like holding it
like that I just let him do this yeah
this video host this is this video above
this video I also saw him do 30 pull-ups
when he was there with Tim Tebow 15 that
big deal hey Jordan Tebow do when he's
30 I would beat him impulses he would
beat me anything legs yeah he was so his
legs are so and I'd said to Tim I go
Brent is stronger than you because he's
competitive huh here's I mean when it
cost some legs not a chance
I'll give him that yeah up or by I beat
him though you beat her an upper body
yeah pull up Dylan yeah I met him once
and I couldn't believe how big he was
yeah what do you think you mean Jesus
Gronk is smaller than him he's a big
rocks not like Tim Tims a free dude
grunts a free Catholic Bronx you mean
obviously Tim psych his I mean his
workouts the Mike Hoadley well you know
but I see like a barrage worker I've
ever met in my life whether it's UFC NFL
there's nobody's more discipline than
Tim Tebow no to the keto diet oh my god
dude you've know you got mad at you he's
like try he's like he's like how much
you know much better you could be he's
like you know he's easy he's a what
would he do if he saw us he's never had
a drink in his life I don't think right
no he did once I think what maybe once I
I don't know he that dude you know
he's the real deal he's a soothing
real-deal great a nice man I love you
just got made he did dimepiece south up
miss South Africa isn't prize yes he's a
good guy no I when I plot to his black
girl just kidding fooled you like girl
Oh can't believe you believed a mealy
nail Peters yeah she's how tall like
when I met jjwong one time and I was
like okay this guy he's 300 pounds
though I was like this guy can this guy
is not Tim it's Jimmy's wife
congratulations Tim they're gonna be
busting kids out like crazy
we have 17 kids yes yes he's ready to go
he's like what's his name he just got
traded to the Colts the Oh Phillip
Rivers
yeah like how many kids he has 11 kids
go mad at poor Norman is he he's Mormon
yeah when he imagine every time he gets
near the house his wife must be like yo
tide here comes dad we're definitely
getting pregnant the next day how many
kids he is that's that's a [ __ ] I
would read that I would love that that
is so impressive holy [ __ ] my aunt had
10 kids my dad's one of I think 11 or 12
I am nightmare
chilling I like how the kid has to just
do it sweater it's just be like pointing
to his his wife is amazing well done
young lady there's goes 9 there yeah
that's it maybe sure he's up to take a
little pit yeah I think she's actually
giving birth in that photo to twins
he's a badass I love his I love that
he's constantly just annoyed on yes and
just talking [ __ ] so intent he's just
gonna and I'd love his attitude that he
doesn't hide it and did you hear when so
I obviously had his whole career in San
Diego and they look at that castle looks
small oh when they moved to LA he
thought he didn't want to move his kids
so he left all of them there they built
one of those Sprinter buses so he would
commute every day when that practice and
the games from San Diego to LA but in
that Sprinter bus he had a whole setup
so you just watch hours and hours of
tape in the house I get to the game be
ready to go that's good it makes sense
just such um he is a stud man he's look
at that big guy by the way he's [ __ ]
huge a duck
how big is JJ Watt compare I manage it
your your quarterbacks uh Russell yes
you love him love him he's so underrated
I feel like well he's everyone always
goes oh he's not that big he's not that
have you seen the legs on that last shoe
on who I know yeah Russell Wilson's on
when I had the Netflix show thank you I
watched a little clapping man he said
alright man no.1 the Netflix show is
tough because Netflix is a it's not like
a regular TV station so here's what
listen here's what I'll tell no uh daily
show basically on Netflix right but but
nobody hit first of all he came in did a
sketch and he accidentally left his
sweatpants and they were like the legs
they were Triple X but like the waist
was taken in but his legs were it's hard
to tell there see how thick is that
they're right there show him running
right there he's short though that's not
you sure thanks fun recorder back yeah
yeah for quarterback but it doesn't seem
to matter
no Jesus I mean look at Drew Brees he's
super stud the Russell Wilson might be
the best way back in the NFL but yeah
people always underestimate him and huge
arse
yep but the guy you can all his also his
twitchy muscle thing yeah I mean you can
be super strong but his twitchy muscle
when you see him make the decision to
run with the ball instead of throw it he
doesn't have a lot of help either
suction ball a 13 get MVP ivory Jackson
and then Lamar Jackson
it's so stupid eat that they give MV
people or the playoffs that that's
really done it so she was he hews damn
be amazing yeah you have half the help
and they almost made it and now is the
we should have beaten the 49ers at home
when Marshawn Lynch that delay again I
can't stop talking about anyway that
said yeah he's such it I like when he
goes hip-hop Russell Wilson I've seen
that not only call sexy just doesn't
really fit his demeanor it's like
awkward in the pictures that's I think
it's for yeah one of these no I mean
looks pretty swag you there he's also a
guy that yeah that's right
yeah this is growing out there like it
yes no he's also one of those guys that
doesn't take a drink
doesn't it me so crazily disciplined
it's a commitment
yeah almost psychotic I feel like
there's almost a superstition like you
don't want to [ __ ] anything up no
they're so disciplined yeah yeah they
don't have dental you don't it's such a
hard job there's so much pressure on
that's how I feel and then I hear that
cork come out of the bottle and I'm like
now yeah buddy we gotta we gotta not
wear our hair like that though obviously
huh well I think you look sweet yeah
well I wish I had that his girls they
[ __ ] Oh have you seen her in prison
sure haven't she's just showed on
Netflix it's a tough oh well - they of
course they I we were one of the first
to go like all right we're gonna do this
thing and I was always going like I know
this sounds like I'm just trying to take
your money but you need to leave us on
for a long time because you did you sell
the show to Netflix yeah oh look there
we are but no I was like just like any
other talk show you need to leave this
thing on for a long time to find an
audience and I was like it's harder with
with it's harder with this streaming
service because that's how and you know
they were like yeah sure buddy were were
the were the most successful company
next to Amazon I would uh but doesn't
work like that but no but so they did I
want of course I was like just leave it
on I have people find it yes and that
obviously wasn't part of that good cuz
that but what's weird is then they
doubled down it cuz they did you this
and then a similar show with Michelle
whoa yeah it was just like these aren't
gonna work because it's not well but
that's why they had to crib in my mind I
like you need to create the you need to
create the atmosphere where people would
go to what every week where they go so
that's why with like like when James
Corden first got on people like who is
this guy nobody knows him and les
Moonves what a guy
he was very smart no I'm around your
girl there's all that other stuff yeah
the part where he was masturbating in
front of his own doctor that's not
recommended yes that's what he and
that's one of the people that smiley and
she was yeah and she he
jerking off in the and like the in the
doctor's office and she walked in and
she goes you have a problem and he was
like I really do that was like part of
the dialogue which was a say I just like
how she what happened what happened with
all of that day pay everybody often just
go quietly into the night lost his gig
but he got paid off like 200 mil yeah it
was yeah he was his wife was a smoke
show too and she's she saw on Big
Brother continues to be she's very nice
Asian but she's off the Julie Chen yeah
she's off the talk but what am I going
back to Oh when James Corden came on he
was just like yeah don't worry people
like we don't know who he is we don't
know if he's gonna last he's like don't
worry about it I'm gonna leave him on
for a year let me figure it out and like
let him figure it out and get his and
then he did a carpool karaoke and it
exploded yeah but it's one of the things
word you think a while you'll eat like
when Conan first went on they gave him a
year you know they and he Oh in Conan
will tell you like they were always like
you gotta be more MIT they were giving
him notes obviously and Conan very
smartly stuck to his guns and now he's a
legend the king but but you gotta let
that stuff I mean like with when I first
did the soup nobody watched it for a
year but because we ticked up like 2.0
ratings point and like appointed just
barely anything on that night and like
at cost nothing let's just leave it on
and then all of a sudden we found that
show your idea or what did you audition
for that because of a show would they
started bringing people in in 2004 to go
if we were to bring back the show in a
certain way what do you do it and so I
know that it brought it they had me do a
I was so dyslexic that I'm they had okay
you're gonna read these jokes that I
wrote with my for these these writers
that I'm the guys that gave me the sword
and we wrote these jokes got written and
I had to memorize it cuz it was so bad
that five minutes of like you just
you've always been that dyslexic so yet
being a stand-up comic pride helps you
because I wasn't a stand-up then oh you
weren't touring them know when science
stand-up 2005 when the show began to
work a year later he went on his agent
like oh you got to go out and you got to
you got it you can get you're gonna make
a bunch of money because people know who
you are and you just bring your comic
friends with you well you know I don't
know if you ever remember me meeting you
a long time ago in a clothing store and
I came up to and sell a van what I was a
fan I don't remember maybe American yeah
it's probably American rice I think was
American Rag and I said I'm a fan sir
thank you and I said are you doing
stand-up I thought yes we totally did
yes and I said you should I think you
said you were starting to or something
it was like I'm crying and yeah was i
eating it well I mean stand up like
anything is I don't give a [ __ ] how
funny you are until you have an act it's
a dick yes it just takes a while it's
just a different thing well it was weird
thing cuz I had this weird because if I
had started when people didn't and know
what wasn't on the show I would have
eaten [ __ ] for and in a good way where I
was like oh that's not funny any but
because they liked the soup they liked
they were like hey it's great and I was
like no and then so then I'd do it in
front of a crowd that didn't know the
show and they'd be like this is the
worst this is worse than the Holocaust
and so I really had to
it took me and after doing hey you know
like 2000 shows yeah yeah then finally I
was like I literally took me along
because sometimes talk to us be like
come on and do stand-up and I was like I
talk a lot about television clips I
don't think it's gonna necessarily
translate but now I way better than I
would I will confidently say way better
than it's all [ __ ] like hard I'm
trying to tour now yeah a ton yeah I do
it I now need cuz I did the special I
need to start over and would you do the
special at San Jose in that San Jose
Charlie Chaplin he'd a time very very
old theater what's it called
live from Pyongyang which I don't think
anybody's watch ah very good
and I went on that Kelly and Ryan show
and I told Kelly the title and she goes
you know no one's gonna know what that
is and I was like yeah you're right very
good I like thanks for the money but the
number of people you'd be amazed at the
number of people that said
how did you do a show in North Korea and
I was like I didn't know do you think
that would be possible I would be shot
yeah I would be in jail I was yes come
let me do a comedy show in front of a
bunch of people who don't speak English
impossible yeah so I don't think it did
very well but you know it's weird you
know he was out coming I did mine with
comedy dynamics as well very nice people
yes what was his name of yours mine was
called complicated Apes that was my one
they called American boner but he was
too much I like American but what did
your boys your dad think of American
bone well he probably wouldn't have
listened to how old your dad almost 80
yeah how proud is he proud I think he is
yeah your dad proud I don't know
where's yeah your dad's proud I don't
know my dad's probably mean you don't
know I don't know
has your dad ever said hey his dad his
dad it's not gonna be his dad's not a
guy who's like great job running but his
dad's quietly very proud right his dad's
a very present man in his life and
always has he doesn't say you're gonna
get a real job
he doesn't say something like that no
he's not my house and so he's in your
house we seized my house he's like well
whatever you're doing works yeah yeah
yeah I once told I just slipped to my
dad somehow it came up how much I was
making at a certain point they have no
clue yeah
and then you then and um I saw some
cousins like a month later and they're
like hey we're here you're making
started telling his brother okay
yeah yeah I'm glad there's some current
events Jenn sure current events yeah
kind of that something we already talked
about we would your life change if I
give you a hundred million dollars uh
well I'd buy more steak yeah I mean I'd
buy a lot more stuff a hundred million
yeah no it would chance for me very
signal what in what sense all over Ryan
Rams example with donation it's finished
I thought oh
this is a really in what in that it
would be a lot more money that I have
yeah would you buy a different house
would you move to different area more
car would your day-to-day if you're
successful dude so it's like what huh no
I wouldn't change houses no I definitely
get a 1966 oldsmobile toronado okay
that's that's 20 grand oh no well but
then I put like a sure so uh boy no I'd
buy I know where it buy another house
we rattle okay uh Don concede that that
thing cool that's with that car yeah so
far I'm not impressed you can do both of
those things right at you 26 grand okay
you're right I can do this you can do it
you can do both those things like for
sale I just asked you
that's you how it would change okay no I
mean you could fly a lot more privately
that's right
no I would be spending I'd be spending
money on private I'd be flying
yeah that's travel but a even that's
what uh what's that rich dude who
donated Oklahoma State the billionaire
the [ __ ] billionaire Dhokla he golf
it Buffett no that's what they asked him
about I try he was I strut here's my
life that really didn't change that's
relative you know I drove by his house
when I was in Nebraska yeah in Omaha I
drove by his house and we stopped and
sir you can't park there
that's it but it's a very biased or
Amanda I did not I did not ruin it
guy was driving us around showed us was
just took us by [ __ ] Buffett's house
because you want to see it yeah he's
nine years old I did like it when you
know like Trump wouldn't review I never
came back from Reserve would improve
realist tax records and then he's buffer
he was like will you have it and then he
did buffer release his taxes yeah any
went your toe right well he's being
audited by the way yeah the time cause
you're stupid me there's no I
wow that's a lot of money I yeah it
would recently there's I'm one I'd like
you guys it sounds like I'm like OCD
workaholic yeah I can't stop yeah no
matter how much they pay no and so that
it will always weird I know I will hold
on to those handlebars with white
knuckles yes where's
come from where do you think that comes
from but don't you think that's why
we're kind of our stance on the
coronavirus where I go back by Easter
let's [ __ ] do it in the Nile some
people I'm chillin [ __ ] [ __ ] I'm
afraid to break I'm afraid of the yeah I
know I want to keep this going man I I
mean I'm not worried about lose I just I
just wanna [ __ ] I want to get back to
where I want to stand up and come on man
no we all yes I think that's why our
that's our perspective like we all know
you're here doing this though right now
and you're not worried about I mean
obviously everyone's been washing the
hell out of themselves but but this is
why you're doing podcasts and and doing
everything else that you can because we
were given that I don't know what it is
that is that hair up our asses I've
always had it comes in our pants that
that's like I think part of it might
come from the fact that you know what
you're capable of doing and you want to
be able to do it before you die but I
enjoy that I just saw I also really
enjoy it I love to work like it's my
passion it's not it's not to me this but
what's the but nobody but let me ask you
what's the feeling you get from that
though right so it's a satisfaction
happiness
no I but let me ask you this in when you
were a walk-in a walk-on at Washington
right you get treated like [ __ ] did you
get a chip on your shoulder from that to
come over to entertainment no I have
that no that was I always I never
thought I was gonna be a good football
player which I always lie I was like I
just want to see if I can do that you're
like Rudy yeah I was like I'm gonna I'm
gonna try my I mean I gained I got up to
like 245 pounds and and I was I was like
what what's happening but that was more
to see if I was more like oh justing it
strange challenge to that that I took up
no but I always knew that I was gonna do
something like this in entertainment yes
but I don't I think this is a the that
I'm never gonna stop working things
that's enhancing the pet that's I think
that's just again like you can deadlift
700 pound this does nothing free right
it does it might not do anything for
buddy but you were given that thing in I
wouldn't you were warmed up to it
you were born like that yeah you were
net there was never an option for you it
was never in your wheelhouse to go well
I mean I go
College and then get a law degree and
that means I'll get a decent job and
I'll make this much money and I'll work
doing this for a long time correct that
was never an option
yeah it's a great option for zillion
people yes but we all win no no I'm
gonna stand on stage and take each hit
for years yes and that's something that
and we don't care we didn't care about
the torture of it no I almost remember
one time I was patty Jenkins we were in
New York City and and I was a young
comic and it was packed
David Tempest is 19 so I was like
where's everything lit with candles
everything was lit with candles and as
chaplain the smalls ox was going on wool
for all I know
and there were no vaccines but I'm ER
Dave Chappelle had been up and and some
other people and and I I was a new comic
and I remember looking at Patti and I go
that they're about to call me up and I
you get so nervous when you're young
yeah and you're gonna do it for a [ __ ]
packed room and I just looked at her I
go hell of a way to try to make a living
and she goes you'll be fine and I
remember going why am I doing this like
those moments if you go why am i doing
something this crazy why am i why am i
what is wrong with me that I hate myself
this much that I have to prove myself
that I have to get up - no no I agree as
you or you're striving for something and
yes yes yes I just wanted to be
different I just wanted to be the person
being talked about as opposed to but
that was nothing that was nothing that
you ever learned that was you that was
always in you but I remember as a kid
watching westerns and and so I would see
the gunslinger and the hero Neutron his
street fighting and I would see the the
I remember when the the barber guy would
be like ooh
and he she got his window he goes he
shut the shutters and lock and be and
retreat inside and as a child as a child
man I remember going I'm never gonna be
that [ __ ] do with the spectacles
who's like hmm I want to be the dude in
the street fighting I remember I wrote
thinking that like like whatever that
was I had to be the one doing the
activity that people were talking and
then you saw a Sweeney Todd and you
realize no way
barbers are just murdered action
fucked-up-ness murderers no ID but I
yeah I yes I think soon as this thing
lifts then we're the only business where
I get maybe it's not work we're calling
our agents going so do you know what I
said to you they start digging now he's
gonna happen I remember I said you when
you started doing stand-up you're making
a lot of money no I said I said you you
were I know you were nervous about it I
was nervous about it it was like
stand-up as a crazy thing but I I said
to you let me ask you something go back
all the way knew we were kid have you
ever not found your way to the near top
yeah in anything you ever did and I've
never done anything in my life where I
didn't find a way to get myself at least
on that varsity team in one way or
another right yeah but I just would
figure it out I just was like what do I
have to do to get yeah I just don't want
to be this and so that is a personality
you said it perfectly and then you
figure it out yeah you figure it out
yeah guy being dyslexic I was terrible
in school so I'm just like I'm just
gonna cheat I'm gonna cheat through
everything that I'm gonna get great
grades because I'm just gonna cheat
whatever you got to do
so when I go to colleges and do stand-up
how was your college experience cheated
every way just taking notes kid it's got
my way thrown yeah but it yes so one
hundred million dollars would it changed
your life
I don't think so it won't be less
stressed yeah I say that I find
something to worry about I would find
something to be your health but as far
as fund really knows change yours I buy
more cars more shoes but no yeah I mean
that's the other that I have a house
that I want to buy I wouldn't try to be
charity I would give I would give more
I'll figure out a way to get more that's
for sure what I would do good and that
would that would come you know I'd I
would I was anyone buying this I mean
yeah no i do that now i do that now i
have charities now that you know i mean
i noticed the guy could never I already
feel like I have too much money so I
already have charities right but I don't
see how I could do have a hundred
million dollars then that really then
the guilt factor would be really through
the roof yeah so I'd have to be like
[ __ ] I'd have to figure out it'd just
be a headache I think I think I you in
one hundred million dollars I tell my
brother quit
job my mom see that's charity you're
gonna take care of people yeah might do
that now yeah but right but if I had a
hundred mil it'd be waived it just Beck
oh no you here's this just stop doing
everything yes but then what happens I
give your brother or whomever a million
bucks and be like here take it and then
two years later though my brother's make
three million yeah yeah he'd be like so
rather would make your brother give some
curved engine current events here we go
what's happening okay this all Crona I'm
gonna freak out okay so a couple days
ago Ryan Reynolds made a statement that
he's gonna be donating 30 percent of all
proceeds from a v8 engine which is his
liquor company to out-of-work bartenders
and Bryan Cranston and Aaron Paul also
did the same thing where and they're
saying that they're gonna donate a
portion of the proceeds from their brand
I believe it's dos hombres they sell
mezcals
mm-hmm they're gonna also be donating to
out-of-work bartenders it's also a great
way to get your your yeah booze out
there it also gives back like it's you
know love it yeah but didn't run realms
give him million dollars to a another
charity
Nina's wife I believe was it through the
aviation gin thing but I know that he
pledged a million I know what ifs Martin
we should have done some ice but Rob
macula hang me from only sunny in
philadelphia he started a GoFundMe and
she's their goal is 50,000 got a hundred
thousand now he's gonna give that I
think to the hospitals or to feed the
hospital's yeah it's pretty dope was a
dak Shepherd and Kristen Bell are doing
something similar where they own a a
real like a company that owns several
different apartment complexes and
they're saying for the month of April
and until the coronavirus is over
they're not gonna charge anybody for
those months in or school so a lot of
people are doing really great things
like this Rob's are my favorite people
matching donations up to twenty five
thousand and they're at a hundred
thousand already
that's a nice what are we doing guys I'd
actually fee in the hospital tonight
paying for the entire staff
dinner look at - no it's not $100,000
Rob least they get food you can ask me
the same question what are you doing Oh
what was the question
no I'm helping the the Union rescue
mission who cause homeless people now 14
feet their donations during times like
this just disappear yeah so right they
literally say do you guys have some
coffee and so we're bringing them much
coffee
yes we'd love coffee what's this so I
believe it was last week we talked about
how pornhub was giving away a bunch of
free premium memberships to people over
in Italy while they were in quarantine
they are doing this worldwide now
business is a-boomin everybody is it
once again a 30 day free trial of
pornhub premium they also said that
they're going to be making donations to
first responders as well as medical
staff within the nation I love you
pornhub this is great news give them
back this is great sex workers outreach
project they're also making it a point
to give all of the money that the models
and sex workers on pornhub would make
they're not taking any cut of that from
that they're giving them all their
protein now can the actors work yeah no
they are and they're getting paid for a
solution terms less than ten so long
term they're working despite the virus
being rampant I think it's the league
yeah and I think there's so many other -
the link is not transferred through see
yeah apparently so
fecal right there's no mouth to mouth
play there's no ass a bouncer that's it
I think mouth to [ __ ] is fine I actually
heard he gets rid of it well this is a
very credible story you know there's a
lab scientist
you just said that was true there is
like your mom in the background that was
she was very good
so cardi's be made a wait what about
Idris what the Prince Charles Prince
Charles he's supposed to be having it to
him that he's 77 71 is he but he died
see I said yeah that's apparently he has
it Michael yo has it did have it how did
he he's fine yeah he was in the hospital
yeah he has it but how'd he get it
his I think this from what I heard
through a third party his wife and child
do not have it but he got it I don't
Travers another strong human being when
he was playing oh y'all played cause do
you want where George no oh yeah Michael
yo yes look at [ __ ] up chin Michael yo
isn't he one fourth alter I told you
that and I've worked with Mike glad
we've never talked I remember when he
started and stand up I never see was it
ZJ right yeah I've never seen his stand
up how is it he's funny you still put up
for jokowi all the time yes Michael's
great great guy he's very nice man ugly
hey wait a minute very nice uh ugly look
at that have you seen his kids just
start good-looking kids biracial babies
are beautiful yeah
Michael Chinese Chinese and black or
something yeah lucky mo but he was them
bad blockers off a block stud cuz I
didn't notice how big he was well I was
like talking like a University of
Arkansas scuse me I played for four
raids I sent two men concussions he came
up how long was he on the Gilders
Wikipedia how long didn't show anything
about football Wikipedia I work so he
got too many concussions and then I have
too many concussions if we all do yeah
it's called football ironically didn't
get well I had a skull fracture skiing
but that wasn't the same they did but
every time I'm you know how it felt
every at the end of every football
practice you just had that's mild like
you just had a beer and a hat like your
Bell guy you're just like oh yeah you
feel spreading a little just a little
boy
yeah all right we call it getting your
bell rung didn't they yeah who would
have known that years later you can
remember anything okay we got down to
the Michael Michael get better feel
better yeah well he played our can any
other uh got a few others you guys want
some more sure the most fascinating part
of the goddamn riders are it is
obviously coronavirus related so this is
Italy's mayors going off there so funny
it's actually a lot no it's pretty it's
only two minutes twenty seconds maybe
watch how they talk to that remember
it's translated though so it's wait they
didn't speak English just move on and
who's this time we go honk a mayor the
mayor's dog yes different mares go to a
place there's some douchey initial yeah
machine condition is true love a kitchen
ordinance hostage or a lock or you know
this is great at si que cela Renault me
Aviva you know TT esta mañana para para
la festival aria
[Laughter]
sound medical advice fair trade nostril
Conchita Dean okay I'm a bill Michaela
la cosecha sulla strada accompany Otto
Don Carney visible Coronado the first
award of a quest to known even filmer
pasta pedasi commentary Tobin is a
continuum only in Jordan illegitimate
father Laspisa cuando las Brisas is a
verified una volta Medici told me
comment October me Jordan Candice a
personas we like to say good Santa
momento Bailey's and I gently by dealer
benzene are now pushed up in see
necrosis a mistletoe veteran in a casa
you see that a spring break Florida kid
whose [ __ ] he got coronavirus yeah no no
he got he got pologize I'm not sure if
you got Corona but I thought he got it
but there are kids in Kentucky that
through a coronavirus party and of
course one of them ended up getting
coronavirus
maybe that's what I heard cuz they're
young right Italians don't follow rules
they're here now they are now they for
the most part [ __ ] off other grad this
portal Portland Oregon so I love pork
it's good she's she's uh she's pretty
young way is the tattoo on her watch is
different weird tattoos so how about the
evil twins on that no jean-claude Van
Damme I think this is it might be oh no
that's from army of darkness so what no
Bruce Campbell yeah it is I thought that
was our the other guy wow that got great
tits and a positive attitude yes ma'am
she said she's that's my kind of lady
right there I love this how many chest
tattoos does your wife have hold on
Atlanta bloom just the tool what do you
say honey chess tattoos does she have uh
well my ax your ex yes she has none she
hasn't the night is your wife Evan eat
at no do you have any no do you kids
know I still get my tats
okay yeah I was like I think I missed
the
I'm in that age where I regret all of
them do you really oh yeah I never my
tattoos up on stage why it's a
distraction of how my party know I got a
full sleeve here see I disagree with
clever and them I think they're good
they look great you know he's a very
successful comic does tattoos are
distracting I describe unless it's your
audience your tattoos well I was told my
comp way back when they're like you
can't be in really good shape and be a
comic those days have definitely changed
yeah and I was like what I heard that
okay they're like you have to have a
comedy body that doesn't make sense
because Eddie Murphy was [ __ ]
shredded in red leather back in the day
yeah he was so stupid those kinds of
those kinds of things and when I hear
that I'm yeah now know cuz I was like oh
maybe I [ __ ] maybe I could just eat I've
been hearing that since 95 I had to
laugh at it what are you talking about
right but sorry my body for you right
now
skinny anyway dammit I know she got chin
goes well or not ain't comedy I will
just want to fish for this one then say
there's just stringer is that yeah these
are strippers at a Portland Oregon club
and then obviously customers to stop
coming in because they're worried about
whether it's a bag yeah so now they
decided to do something called Boober
eats would they would just go up to you
know they would order food the customers
order food they would show up and first
it was just they were just showing their
tits but now they're covering them up
with pasties yeah and then I assume I do
a little dance or way more angry
last time I was in Portland's at the
helium there and I went to go find this
Mexican place so everyone told me go eat
up this make sense place I go to go the
the bathroom and there's a bathroom here
and there's a black door in the right I
go through the black door on the right
and it's a strip club
so oldest strip club in Portland it's
fantastic Wow how older enchilada
burrito Levi was with strippers not this
one okay dear Posen Chapelle lasing
realizing that's Portland though you
know have the most strip clubs per
capita than any other city not Atlanta
nope Portland number one look at that
alright well that's pretty much it
that's I mean the news everything is all
coronavirus this was another one that
Conor McGregor really went off he wants
Ireland it basically go into full
lockdown mode
he also released a statement though
about the goat is Twitter because he
really released the numbers people send
them the numbers of the success rate as
well someone just sent me this good news
the success rates like 98 percent
there's 18 thousand tests 94 percent
success rate
we're just on it right now by 4 percent
negative no 94 percent success rate
meaning if you get it you're fine yeah
out of 18,000 people yeah
ninety-four percent are fine a six
percent the doozy
yeah then your but see but even the
numbers game right so that but the
problem wouldn't they go like it's so
sick yeah you're gonna be fine
the problem is if a zillion people it's
so contagious zillion people get it but
still the hospitals are flooded that's
the problem we don't have that we don't
have so it's when I hear Bledsoe like
you're just gonna be perfectly fine he's
like yes if you have mild symptoms to
riff I need a respirator stay at home
you might not but but that still means
if if you get the one was it may be in
the lab that was a nurse and she says
their hospitals kind of dead because so
many people are scared that they don't
know if they have it for sure they think
through the hospital didn't be
surrounded with people that have it so
they're not coming in now I heard
ibuprofen is nice to help know that
they're saying it makes it worse in kids
it's possible no no real studies that's
what their show me what Connor was
saying there's also read that zit like
people like kids Inc and then I looked
it up and they're like yeah it doesn't
they're saying vitamin C helps and z-pak
that would be so money and you know a
hydro I just said yeah but you can see
just take your Hydra crook
Quine hydrochloric wine yeah well then
there's that Roxy chloroquine that it
definitely helped that's a malaria drug
this simply then there's that guy in
Arizona who took the he died but he took
a different version and he did it right
but that's the problem when they go we
think it could be this yeah but like
well is close enough yeah dum-dum I did
I misread it didn't people say our
people of diets that's hit it Jen
goddamnit he is very impassioned in this
hello everyone do you think he could
beat him Brennan oh that's a look of a
man that could be my
Higgens device ab let me put it
fullscreen hello everyone hello Ireland
I would like to address my nation to the
people of Ireland to our presence
nervously Higgins to Vice Admiral mark
mallet to Grider Commissioner drew
Harris chief medical officer Tony
Hoolihan Leo the two assignments Mary
and me Hall are especially well greatly
and I would like to plate a minute
Houlihan's on this I want to say that we
are all currently debating a full
lockdown I feel that we must any time
spent debating this is needless time
from the clock I know a good to fight
when I see one and we have one on our
hands now I want to call upon my people
that great people of Ireland this fight
needs us all we are all in the red
corner together awaiting the bail
so let's gather together and ring the
bell our selves including the people of
the rest of the world true lock they all
must begin and it must refer to every
country I lock down together a lockdown
United we must close our airports we
must close all non-essential business we
must cook all non-essential travel
Commissioner Harris and Vice Admiral
Mellott we must prepare and deploy you
could use of this platform our country
now president Higgins you must give
these great men and women the power to
enforce this task if necessary
surprisingly it's in the politics my
friend when the true seriousness of this
is on the store oh he could he could be
the president yeah I love what if like
he's no no was his vice president
looking everybody arriving he might beat
185 really yeah so did chunk yeah that's
it he's 185 he might be there he gets
pretty big yeah weighs about 50 pounds
oh shoot listen I feel terrible we're in
the middle of a pandemic and you came on
the podcast now you've been battering me
about emotion I don't I don't I don't
know you too so you see it didn't I feel
terrible no you don't see you feel
you're going crazy that's staying at
home know that every to second throw
their boys well and they socially they
can talk with their friends yeah
and I do all that yeah so when they get
on a fortnight game or like there's
eight guys from like my 12 year olds
class that they're they're all playing
it I'll chill they're all chatting and
they're I would have loved it pretty if
I was like 12 on Michael [ __ ] you I
don't have to go to say it's cool
hell yeah Oh weights I think for
numerous kids it's it's it's heaven I
don't want to say you've been in a very
serious time when crazy shits happening
but I think yeah the kids have that same
sort of like oh no well yeah we don't
have to go to school yeah for high
school seniors kind of sucks though no
no prom no sports yeah well think about
any great yet graduations and well can
like Ken Jong was gonna do the Duke
commencement speech oh that's right and
that's not gonna happen
ken Jeong oh you do that's what will end
on the shooting or right and John Ken
Jeong Jeong oh what's that pronunciation
is that what pain what part of Korea I'm
glad you asked address from the
outskirts of Seoul why did you say Seoul
that way now you're singing him you do
mass singer with him though right I've
done it yeah I do like twice a you like
a guest judge yeah fun times have you
seen that show be no no I it's anchored
I hated it at first like what the [ __ ]
these people were in suits and then it
was on TV and I kind of get into it you
know I don't like is the judges I'm sure
I don't know if you've done this but
they're like is that Beyonce behind the
[ __ ] skeleton suit like hey man
Beyonce so I can do the show you know
I'm saying well you never know you're
right right here on Fox for enough money
but Ken and I are doing a podcast I
should mention oh yes oh yes he's an
actual doctor and so we're like oh well
who can John okay John great I pasted
McKenna and I oh I was like why wouldn't
you in Canada has it started or no we're
literally in a tape it cuz we were like
we should talk about
we should talk because he's very good at
the medical stuff and I'm really good at
as you can tell
insulting people ya know I love Kate
Brandis very great idea oh good that'd
be a good well next I figured if we ever
get a place like this you can have this
I'm retiring any much you can have this
you're retiring yes let me be a good man
your posture okay normally it's not
really a guest I don't know it's just a
family members share revenue okay how
much money you guys make can I get hot
we came here by by chopper that's Luber
chopper uber chopper yeah isn't that
Blackbird service yes it is you ever
done that no that's that Hoover for yeah
there's played Blackbird different
months I would like to do it you now I
can sense that things are coming to an
end but I want to know why this is just
starting we've been here for two hours
and 23 minutes is this a record well no
yes rogon does like three hours now
you're an excellent guest yeah you're
great fantastic very true we love you
alright in conclusion what have we
learned
we've learned that your 6-4 year of
Scandinavian descent conspiracy theories
ah thank you only conspiracy theories
you know my you know I enjoy Christian
theories yes yes it could be a which
could very well be a conspiracy taught
me how to make a stake me and Brian are
going to hell well I didn't say that
your friend said that yep you're right
you if anybody's going to hell it's me I
don't know yeah well you're a banker I
love drinking yeah we should we should
do a little wine so you like wine I'm a
wine but I'm wishing you know much wine
I when I way too much no we know that
when when things get back to normal
we need to go that steak house yes we do
I'll take you and I'll full disclosure I
invested in it so oh yeah mandate yeah
but I wouldn't have invested in if I
didn't go like oh he's the grazing yes
oh well I'm there
oh and get your deal cat give me ten
cent oh my number advice for sometimes
oh yeah group text I'm gonna head over
there right now to pick up some of their
takeout Wow so jello damn it I'm gonna
get there short ribs alright oh my god
Joe but I have a filet at home that I'm
gonna split with my wife and I'll tell
you how I cook a filet the next time
you're the best man thank you this the
fine kid we're out